foreign
hey John yes ma'am I am calling a bit of
an audible here
I was on time today I bathed
I did all the things yes
and oh is this his highlighted thing yes
so we didn't schedule a call for this
segment because I found something
actually something was sent to me by one
of our other associate producers from
Tick Tock that I wanted to talk about oh
yeah that's this is my favorite subject
Tick Tock well it's not about Tick Tock
but so there's a woman on tick knock on
Tick Tock good Lord what are these ask
doc Courtney she is a trauma therapist
and she posts um she had posted recently
some little sticky notes that just had
quotes that her young clients had said
to her over the past couple of weeks and
I wanted to read these to you just so
you know she got permission to post
these there's no names or anything but
I'm going to read you what they said and
then how old the person was and then I
want you to respond to him yep for that
let's do it all right this will be
awesome if the trauma therapist says
things that I've said exactly this this
is like the world's saddest lightning
round just to let you know all right the
first one this is from a six-year-old if
I ran away my parents wouldn't know they
don't say good night anymore
oh my gosh
so children
have one love language in its presence
not presence like wrapped up with a bow
on top but presents
p-r-e-s-e-n-c-e at bedtime it I think is
one of the most critical times because
the whirling dervish energy stops if you
do one thing parents
have dinner with your kids the research
is really clear on that the second thing
is have a bedtime routine where you get
to touch your kid on the face look him
in the eye and say I love you hope
you've had a great day what's your best
thing to happen what's the hardest thing
to happen and I'll be here in the
morning golly
all right the next one is from a 16 year
old
being alone in my room is okay it
doesn't mean I'm suicidal or sad
man
yeah as kids get older
um this is hard man so as when kids are
younger parents often use their kids and
their questions and their ability to
give wise answers to these little kids
and they're driving them all over the
community as a way to fuel their
self-esteem I am who I am because I do
all these things for this kid and this
kid relies and needs me
the only kid turns 15 16 or 17 they
start developing autonomy I just need
some space I need some time to think I
need to wrestle with the world I got to
do homework I don't have time to talk to
you I don't have time to I don't want to
do gymnastics anymore just so you feel
better about yourself
and then parents begin knocking on the
door what about me what about me what
about me
come out of your room what are you doing
in there why are you checking on your
kid is very important letting you know
your kid know they're loved is important
but also giving them some time
to have their own space and moms and
dads if you feel oh man you're getting
me fired up if you feel like well who am
I then that's a you problem not a kit
problem for your 16 year old to solve
ugh okay go ahead
as a parent of a 16 year old I don't
like that one
all right this is from another 16 year
old my mom says in a minute and hours go
by this is why I yell this is why I yell
in demand she forgets me
dude guilty is charged on this one
guilty is charged
parents and you say in a minute that
means 60 seconds to your child
unless you lie to them and one minute
means 14 minutes or 30 minutes or when I
get done looking at this website or I
get done scrolling Instagram or
Pinterest for a while
say in 10 minutes say 15 minutes
and when your kid starts yelling and
demanding your attention remember
behavior is a language
don't ask yourself why is that kid
causing such a ruckus
ask yourself what is that my kid trying
to tell me oh
they don't know how to say hey Dad
you're a liar hey Mom you're a liar they
do know how to say look at me over here
oh you won't look at me I'll smash this
vase I'll do something because I just
need to know that you love me okay
all right I'm called out on that one
from a 15 year old lying to me when I
ask if you are okay makes me not trust
myself I am connected to you yep that
goes back to one of the things I've said
over and over on this show
um
if you're not okay the one of the
greatest gifts you can give your kids is
to be honest with them because if you
don't they're gonna think they're crazy
because they feel you not being okay and
they're gonna wonder what is wrong with
them that mom lies to me the death
doesn't tell me the truth they're going
to wonder what is it about Mom that I'm
doing to make her not feel okay so if
you're not okay if you have a bad day at
work you got a hard day at work your
boss laid into you you've got troubles
in your marriage you got Financial
challenges obviously don't tell the kid
we're gonna lose the house
but do let them know yeah Mom's under a
lot of stress
and sometimes I don't do a good job
letting you know that I love you and
this my stress isn't your fault
but I'm so grateful for you right being
honest with your kid don't ever say the
words nothing honey it's fine because
that's a lie it's a lie and it's a lie
that's gonna make your kids feel crazy
all right from a seven-year-old I feel
like a bad kid when I make a mistake
usually because my parents think I did
it on purpose
they don't think you did it on purpose
here's what parents think they think
that kids are their report card
that kids are their scorecard and when
kids mess up it's a reflection of me
you left the milk out which somehow ties
back to me being a bad parent not being
you you being 12 and you don't you're
off in la la land or you didn't get
enough sleep or I'll let you eat seven
hamburgers yesterday nothing to do with
that has to do with you're my scorecard
you're my walking report card
and every mistake you make as a 7 9 12
17 year old reflects on me and that's
bullcrap parents stop
kids make mistakes why because they're
kids
we teach them we hold them accountable
but they're kids they're kids man jeez
sorry I can hear you breathing these are
getting fired up man
all right um this is from a
nine-year-old my mom is too busy she
says but she texts her friends all day
why not tell the truth she's just
avoiding me
nine-year-olds ten-year-old
six-year-olds 15 year olds 15 year olds
do
little kids don't know how to ask hey
Mom why are you avoiding me they just
internalize it and they Wonder
what's so much why does she love that
little shiny box more than me
what is so annoying about me
what is that little shiny box have that
I don't have
and those kids will spend the rest of
their life making up stories about it or
trying to solve it either through
burning your house down or making
Straight A's and marrying the perfect
person
because they're trying to win your love
any Mom isn't trying to avoid you
but that's a story a nine-year-old makes
up so they can sleep at night because
Mom's spending more time with the little
digital box than she is with her kid
put your phones down parents and this is
me this is the pot talking to Kettle
here man geez Louise these are
convicting Kelly thanks for ruining my
day I was already having a not great
parenting morning so thanks for kicking
me while I'm down sure all right uh 10
year old taking away all that I love
doesn't motivate me it makes me feel
hopeless yes okay listen
I probably need to do a whole segment on
the show on this
um
when you punish a kid with I can do what
I want because I got bigger muscles than
you or I've got more power than you you
did this so I'm taking away this you did
this so I'm not taking you to the zoo
anymore you did this so no video games
for you
the kid doesn't get the correlation they
then start acting so that they don't
lose relational Capital with Mom and Dad
not actually they don't actually learn
and adapt to the new behaviors that we
want
that's why it's so important to teach
kids that they get to choose
so in my house there's Seasons when if
my son gets in trouble and he can't I
don't know but let's pretend we had an
Xbox we don't have one of those but if
we had an Xbox
and he makes a bad grade I can go in and
say you got a bad grade so I'm taking
the Xbox which is me saying I've got
bigger muscles and I've got power and
you your life will be about what I want
no
I will say hey in this house we have
this standard of academic Excellence
nothing is more important than your
grades and your character right now and
here's the standard I've set you can
choose to meet it or not cool your
choice and so if you don't meet it
you're just choosing to not play Xbox
for the next six weeks that's cool
that's your choice
and my son is going to learn that he has
responsibilities and choices in his life
and the consequences are things that he
chooses you can choose to not drive the
speed limit and you're choosing to get
tickets you're choosing to go to jail
you're choosing to kill somebody
crossing a street that's your choice and
there's consequences and accountability
on the back end of it not you can't you
see what I'm saying golly dude don't
flex on your kids they're kids
teach them how to make choices
sorry
all right
Kelly this is a 13 year old telling me
that you're disappointed in me kills me
I didn't do what I did to hurt you I was
just learning
oh boy
you answered this one Kelly
no thank you
um parents your 13 year old should not
have the power
to regulate your emotions because you're
an adult and they're a child
I don't give my kids the power to make
me mad I sometimes choose to be angry
and I use that kind of language my kids
don't have the power to frustrate me I
can choose to be frustrated and I let
them know I'm choosing to be frustrated
right now because I've asked you four
times to do X Y and Z and you've chosen
not to I'm choosing to be frustrated
but I don't tell them if you do that I'm
gonna get mad or if you do something I'm
going to be really disappointed in you
you don't have that kind of strength or
power because I'm an adult and you're a
child
parents when kids feel like they are
responsible for the emotional regulation
of the adults in their life they crumble
under the weight because they can't
carry it because they're kids
so if you find yourself angry you find
yourself frustrated you find yourself
lashing out you find yourself all raged
out and mad at your kids that's a you
problem not them
you have to ask yourself what is it
about a nine-year-old that is making me
lose control what is it a foot about a
16 year old that's making me rage out
that's a you question
not a 16 year old kid question
because here's my promise that 16 year
old gets compliant real fast you're
still going to have that rage you're
just going to direct it at your boss at
your partner you're going to direct it
at the mail man you can direct it at
politics because
that's a rage problem that you have your
kid's just an easy target
you solve you quit asking your kids to
carry you uh your emotions ugh okay
there we go next one uh 13 year old hey
I can just feel people like
unsubscribing as we go down like I'm out
I'm out I'm out no I don't think so
because I think that as parents we all
see ourselves in some of these uh from a
13 year old when I annoy my mom it's
because I want her attention I don't get
it any other way
yeah
um it goes back to the first the first
one up here
um the the number one way kids absorb
love is through presence
not always attention but presence
mom is here with us in the room she's
not sitting there like an organic lump
of matter but she's two thousand miles
away on Pinterest or Dad is sitting
there on the chair with his feet propped
up watching TV he's not with us
presence is a huge deal and kids will go
to the ends of the Earth it was when a
trauma psychologist it was a buddy of
mine told me hey dude you know Straight
A's is a trauma response too sometimes
and I was like uh say what and he's like
yeah dude kids who don't get adult
attention will set something on fire
they'll hit somebody in the face they
will become emotionally disregulated or
they'll be the best player on the
baseball team
they'll give up every weekend of their
life chasing a silly little ball
traveling all over God knows we're
spending tens and tens of thousands of
dollars of their parents money just so
Mom and Dad will look at them and say
we're proud of you
kids will give it all up
including their freedom they will they
will take punishment if you'll just show
them that you're present with them and
sometimes it takes a kid hitting
somebody or burning something down or
dropping something for parents to snap
out of their La La Land and just be
present
be present man
my parents are better off divorcing I
feel like I'm having I'm just talking to
myself
I'm just talking really frustrated to
this camera here I'm just talking to
myself because good gosh almost all
these are just calling me out here
ah all right this is an eight-year-old
my parents are better off just divorcing
they stay together for my siblings and I
when an eight-year-old says that here's
what an eight-year-old says I my body
can't handle the tension in my home
anymore
I need it to stop
it's the same as when somebody says they
are considering Dying by Suicide I've
never met one that really wants to be
dead
I've met almost all of them really want
to stop hurting
and so I can almost guarantee you this
eight-year-old doesn't want divorced
parents
his body is craving peace
and there's some real incredible
literature that suggests a couple who
chooses and I use that word
intentionally a couple who chooses to
have a good marriage they make that
decision every day every week every
month every year
they live longer their health is better
the their legacy changes their kids
lives are better and
adults who choose miserable marriages I
just fell out of love shut up parents
who choose
adults who choose bad marriages
um they have shorter lives their kids
are a mess and on and on and on
and so I think I really believe this I
think almost every marriage is
salvageable
almost everyone barring a couple of
outside of the bell curve issues
if you refuse to be adults and choose to
have a joyful marriage choose to get
help for your challenges choose to learn
some new skills on how to communicate
together choose these things
then yeah that year old's probably right
because then you're choosing to make
your kids miserable and you're choosing
to die early and why would you choose
that right but date your old man I wish
my parents are just divorced now what
he's saying is
I wish the fight he would stop I wish
the tension in that home would stop I
wish I could sleep without having to
cover my face up with my pillow and
block my ears that's what that
eight-year-old saying and that breaks my
heart man
all right uh 10 years old I love my mom
and dad even when they yell at me I
always love them I wish they I wish I
knew that they loved me as much
[Music]
don't yell at your kids
parents don't yell at your kids
yelling at your kids is trauma it it
dysregulates them
it overwhelms their response system
don't yell at your kids because this kid
said it perfectly they still love you
and they're Tethered to you they can't
move
when you're in a bar and you're throwing
punches at somebody they can run out the
door
when you're a 10 year old and your dad
is yelling at you they got nowhere to go
and their bodies can't absorb it
parents don't yell at your kids
hey let's do some more Kelly gosh last
one huh hey we'll do one more but you
gotta promise the next time it's gonna
be all just joyful things yes it'll be
puppy dogs and rainbows I promise well
puppies poop everywhere well actually
this one's about the dog so we probably
shouldn't use puppy dog let's do it
let's do it this is from a
seven-year-old my dog gets more
attention dad says it's because the dog
can't talk so I stopped talking
I don't think I even need to respond to
that
this father isn't worthy of that
seven-year-old's love
No One's Gonna Make My
uh yeah I'm gonna leave with that I'm
out